hey guys this is Pete peppers with candy
crush soda saga tips calm and this is a
candy crush soda saga level 4 70 video
with some commentary and tips to let you
see how I went about beating it it's a
pretty tough level in the latest episode
so I'm gonna jump right in and go ahead
and talk about how I get through it
first room it's really they're sort of
like an awkward shape here so main thing
we want to do is make some space at the
top in the very beginning and you can
see just ready from there how whenever
things are cascading you can get stuff
to happen so that doesn't happen when
they're in the middle so you get rid of
those pieces and then we're gonna look
for stuck like and that didn't really go
where I wanted it to go but when you get
a horizontal striped or the fish it'll
help out a lot also match these two
together like that because that will
take a whole row and there aren't
actually any fish in the bottom row here
so we're just focusing on the two that
are almost destroyed now
definitely the blue is the best choice
there because it hits the row that has
the Bears I'd like to drop down this
this combo if I can I don't know about
being able to but where it's at now at
least it'll hit the top top row so and
get rid of those licorice coils so
that's not too bad so we'll go ahead and
we can't really make a match because the
green will shoot off so we should just
go ahead and match this
yeah I think I think these are just they
set up things a little bit but yeah and
we're gonna need to just make this
alright so we have two bears left on
this board you can see where they both
are the orange will give them one hit a
sprinkle show and then go ahead and make
this
that'll travel down into the next room
with us and we want to remember where
that's at and just go ahead and we'd do
red or blue blue I guess would be good
because it would take that out all right
so now you see we have some specials
already ready to come down so we're
gonna want to try to bring those down
second room is a tough one
it is the dispensers in the real metal
really make a mess but we got through
the first one pretty fast so we have a
decent number of moves here so we're
gonna look for we're gonna look for some
combos so that a will like this one that
we just set up then I'll take out the
top part of it and the reason for doing
that and something I noticed when I
played this just now was sprinkle shell
you can recharge him pretty fast when
there's enough pieces on the board so
you need to open up some real estate so
that you can do that and then you can
use him multiple times in a row if the
if the blue is in the right place to use
it so this is another great combo right
here the licorice links aren't I mean
they're sorted in a way but it's nothing
to you don't really have to focus too
hard on those you're really just looking
to make combos at this point
it would be great if we could make that
bring that wrapped and color bomb
together but I'm not sure if we'll be
able to do that or not while we're
trying to do that you know we want to
make sure that we're getting cascading
pieces coming down that's the only way
to get action going and now that we have
most of that honey in the middle gone
we're in a pretty good spot so I kind of
gave up on on that for now and I'm just
going to go ahead and use the color bomb
to get that row and now look here we
just go to sprinkle shell so if we get a
decent cascading collects some more blue
he'll fill up again pretty fast and with
these last five moves we want to keep
that in mind because there's still a lot
of honey left and we're gonna need to
use him a couple more times if we wanna
be able to get done with this so yeah
you know I a lot of times you know you
want to do something a little bit better
with that but the Cascade is good and
we're gonna use it on blue and hopefully
he'll charge straight back up and he did
and now we can use it on green and
that'll finish things off so it's a
tough level but you can do it make sure
you keep in mind everything I just said
and I hope you get it soon please leave
a like a second to like the video if you
found it helpful and make sure you
subscribe to the Pete Pepper's channel
so that you can find out one of all the
new videos come out and I'll be making
more soon so I'll talk to you then